Vô nhân viên ở thành phố Vinh bị bắt quyền. Nếu kích hàng lên tiếng xí lỗi, phố cùng biết ở nguyên video tà thử.
Mới đây, một tay khoản có tên được hát thách, được châu là lựa khách hàng bắt nhân viên quyền xí lỗi.
Ở một nhà hàng đướng sạch thành phố Vinh đã có bài đặc lên tiếng xí lỗi nạn nhân và cộng lắm mạng,
tôi sinh trên thành nhận trên nghiệp về sự việc đã sẽ sát tại quán cơ gơ.
Khi trong lúc bất đình tính và thử kìm chế, tôi đã có những hình viên sài trái không đúng mực.
Và khi ra tự vinh sâu sắc châu chào ká hát, giềm viên của quán tôi bố cùng hội hận về hành động của mình,
và nhìn tức só sản mình đã hành sự không đúng với đạo lúc, sản này,
nếu một ngon tảng mấy mồn nè vai ngàn cũng trọng hành mi tư, tôi và sên đing,
cùng với còn li quay nhà hàng gơ gơ. Đã thập mặt sà đình chào ká hát, tôi sinh hòn tòa nhận chách nghiệp và càng kết thắc cuộc tất cả hục quả.
Điều sà đình hãy chào ká hát yêu cầu, su hiệp tạc hãy trong tương lai,
tài buổi các mặt có sự chừng kiến của công an phường quý tế và đại sĩ nhà hàng gơ gơ,
tôi đã thành tâm sinh lối, thương nhận xa là vừa sự trái đạo đất của mình.
Sa đình và chào ká hát, đa chấp nhận lời sĩ lỗi của tôi,
sản sản thà thứ và không yêu cầu tế mất gửi tượng nào về mặt tất chất,
hãy pháp lý, tôi hiểu rằng mình không thể lấy bất kỳ lý sâu nào để biệt miên cho anh vi tử chình bực đó.
Tôi sinh người lời sĩ lỗi sâu sắc nhất đến chào ká hát và ra đình.
Vì những hình đậu đã làm cho biết anh hưởng nghiêm chào,
và hình vý sài trái của mình,
để là một mạnh học sách mà tổ sẽ không bao giờ quên và tôi hi vọng nhận được sự thà thứ từ vận người.
Mình vẫn bài viết từ tệ khoảng nưu hát hát.